stranded and Australia's unforgiving
outback for almost two weeks
this remote territory has previously
claimed lives but Tamra Macbeth Riley
survived 12 full days with little
supplies in the scorching heat three was
a partner and a friend going off to a
bit of fall driving over to chambers
pillar and I took a wrong turn basically
and ended up being bold and experienced
um something I would want to experience
again the group set off from Alice
Springs on Tuesday 19th November they
were planning a trip to chambers pillar
but took a wrong turn and got stuck in
the riverbed in remote territory Tamra
was found nearly two weeks later after
extensive police searches her friend and
partner who split up to walk to Stuart
Highway are still missing
when the helicopter found me I thought
it was mine immediate thought so to find
it it's not the case is why for three
days the trio stayed at the car they dug
a hole in the sand to keep cool living
on a supply of just six liters of water
ten cans of ice vodka and a packet of
biscuits when these ran out there was no
option but to move on
we found a cowboy hole do these were
these and you go do what I do we had to
drink from that's why and then we moved
a little bit further which had a lot
more trees so we had a bit more shelter
- it's getting really hot and it had a
saltwater waterhole there as well it's a
drink from that but at least we could
get cool for when it was really hot
during the day and it was freezing at
nighttime
helicopters were dispatched and found
Tamara about a mile from the car after a
local cattle ranchers spot it's higher
tracks and phone the police it's quite a
diverse terrain there's sandy dunes
there's hard play there's areas of dense
trees but there's also rocks and range
ranges in the area as well so it's quite
a diverse terrain that and
challenging terrain to looking Tamara is
being treated in hospital for
dehydration and exposure but while she
recovers the search for her partner and
friend continues in one of the most
remote parts of the world in Zaman
reseed Sky News